SHARP: Welcome.
I'm Philip Sharp.
And it is a real pleasure to be
able to introduce my colleague
Eric Lander to present a
talk on the historic event
of the sequencing
of the human genome.
When historians look
back on these decades
of biological
science that bracket
the change of the century
and the millennium,
the most noted advance
will be the sequencing
of the human genome.
This sequence will shape all
biological and medical science
that is done postgenomic.
And, in fact, it is the
definition of that word,
"postgenomic."
The consequences of
having the sequence
will not be fully realized
until decades have passed.
There are many stories
for MIT in this event.
First there's the story of Eric
Lander, educated at Princeton
as an undergraduate, PhD
in Mathematics at Oxford,
then a faculty
member at Harvard,
in the Business School.
His first relationship
was with MIT
as a fellow in the
Whitehead Institute,
studying human genetics.
Shortly thereafter,
he became a professor
in the Department of Biology
and a member of the Whitehead
Institute.
He began the Human
Genome Project at MIT
and is director of
the Human Genome
Center, which is affiliated
with the Whitehead Institute.
The second story
is the relationship
between the Whitehead
Institute and MIT.
This relationship, which began
in a highly debated experiment
some 15 years ago, has been
an unqualified success.
The Whitehead Institute
has produced great science,
some of which we
celebrate today,
has produced great
leaders in science,
and has played a full
role in education at MIT,
as typified by Eric's
outstanding lecturing
in the Core Biology
course here in 10.250,
which he does in the fall.
Finally, there is the story of
the human genome sequence, what
it tells us about
our past and future,
how the sequence was determined
in an international effort,
and what it will
mean for humanity.
This story will be told
by Eric, the scientist who
led the team that
contributed the largest
portion of the sequence
to the public effort
and who has been
its best spokesman.
MIT can be proud that
one of its faculty
has accomplished an
historical first--
the sequencing of
the human genome.
Eric.
[APPLAUSE]
LANDER: Let me start by-- oh--
I have no voice, by the way.
One of the casualties
of this week,
which has been a
rather intense week,
is that my voice seems to
have been lost somewhere
between here and Washington.
So those of you who are
used to my lecturing in 701
may detect a somewhat more
painful version of it today.
But, in any case, let
me correct one thing
Phil said right at
the end, because I
think it's very important.
One of its faculty
members has completed
the sequencing of the genome.
Of course-- and I
know Phil means it--
what happened is, about
250 people here at MIT
and the Whitehead
Institute have completed
this remarkable project of
sequencing the human genome.
Because I think one
of the really most
important aspects
of this project
is that nobody
can do this alone.
This was the first example of
a truly, truly collaborative
effort of enormous
proportions in biology.
And I don't think it will be
the last of those efforts.
I think we've learned
that there are projects
that we need to
get done to provide
the infrastructure
for our field,
to provide the tools that the
single, smart graduate student
and postdoc can use for
her or his experiments.
And that we need to work
together, to make those tools.
And I think, before
I go anywhere,
I want to say how tremendously,
tremendously honored
and pleased and proud
I am to have gotten
to work with so many
people here, together,
in this community,
to get this job done.
And any one of us
had a small part,
but what I can say definitely
is, if we here at MIT
had not pulled
together to do this
it wouldn't have gotten done.
And that's a pretty good thing.
If not any one of us
was essential to us,
this community was
absolutely essential to it.
So this is very much
a shared talked,
but I'm very honored to talk
about it on behalf of all
the people here who did it.
I'm looking out
upon the community.
I see members of the genome
center here, which is great.
I see 701 students here,
some of my 701 students,
because I lecture
here in the fall
and I'm glad to
see you back again.
And many of my colleagues
in the Biology department.
And then there are
probably are a whole lot
of people who are not
biologists at all who
just came because they were
to find out what in the world
was going on with the
Human Genome Project.
And I'm going to try to be
able to speak appropriately
to everybody and just talk a
little bit about what went on,
what we learned from it,
and where it's all going.
Let me just dive right in.
The Human Genome
Project and Beyond.
The Human Genome Project was
an absolutely ludicrous notion,
proposed in about 1985--
maybe '84, '85-- that we could
determine the entire sequence
of the human genome
and that this
would provide incredibly useful
information for all of biology.
Both of those propositions were
open to tremendous challenge--
the first, that
we could do this.
At the time, DNA sequencing
was less than a decade old.
DNA sequencing was practiced
with radioactive slab
gels held up against
film, to detect sequences.
It was stunningly inefficient.
It was not that long
before that point
that people got
whole graduate theses
for sequencing of a
couple of thousand letters
in some plasmid.
And here the field was talking
about a million times more
sequencing than that.
In addition, it was hotly
debated whether this
was worth anything at all.
Everyone-- not "every"--
many people said, well,
what would you do with
that information, anyway?
Who needs it.
And the truth was, with regard
to both of those propositions,
the critics were right.
We had no clue how in
the world to do this.
If anybody had gotten up in
front of Congress and said,
we know how to sequence
the human genome,
they would have been
guilty of perjury.
Thank god nobody had
to say that under oath
to get this project started.
And if anyone said, we
know exactly what we're
going to do with
the information,
they would have been
lying to you, too.
But what happened was
a marvelous process
of scientific progress,
in the latter part
of the '80s, when a number
of different committees
and a number of
different countries
different discussions
got together and refined this
project from what it was first,
some megaproject,
into a number of steps
that would produce intermediate
results that would immediately
have feedback to science and
would involve dozens and dozens
of groups around the world.
This is just a timeline
of some of the events--
with a mammalian-centric
point of view,
because we here at MIT
and Whitehead have taken
a mammalian-centric
point of view--
of building the genetic maps
that let you trace inheritance.
That was the first
thing-- just landmarks.
Not so many of
them, a few thousand
that would let you trace
inheritance and families,
making those maps
better and better
through three different
generations, shown here
in colors.
Then, once you found
by tracing inheritance
that there's a gene in
a particular region,
you would get the piece
of DNA by a physical map
from that region.
And you would study it, to
try to find the disease gene.
But then, of course,
what you'd really
like to do is sequence
all those pieces of DNA,
so that, instead of having to
do lots of laboratory work,
you would just double-click
with your computer and up
would pop what you wanted.
That, of course, being the
dream of biology experiments.
In 1985-- sorry, 1996--
began a pilot project for
the sequencing effort, when
a number of groups
around the world
got together and said
we'd try to work out
the methodologies for doing
large-scale sequencing,
being able to do the
process at high quality,
produce finished sequence
at the end, to automate it.
And this was designated as about
a three-year pilot project.
And that is indeed
what happened.
In the spring of 1999, there
was a dramatic scale-up,
because we entered
the production phase.
And, over the course
of the next year or so,
the vast majority of the
sequence got covered.
It involved a tremendous
change in technology.
When we began, in borrowed
space in the cancer center,
we were using
single-channel pipetters.
The great advance following that
was eight-channel pipetters.
[LAUGHTER]
Some favored the
12-channel pipetter.
But, over the course
of the decade or so,
we advanced and
advanced to the point
where now the genome center
over at the Whitehead Institute
is filled with
robots of this sort.
There are picking robots
that go around with cameras,
picking bacterial clones
that had their picks
96 colonies, dunks it
into grow, it picks 96.
And, in the course of a
day, we pick about 120,000
bacterial colonies.
We then have to grow
them up overnight,
and we have to purify them.
Many of you in the audience
have done plasmid preps before,
and then set up
sequencing reactions.
It's a tedious operation.
This is how we do them now.
This is the production
floor for doing plasma preps
and sequencing reactions.
Onto those conveyor belts--
which use a new kind
of biochemistry,
a solid-phase reversible
mobilization that was developed
at the genome center.
Onto these conveyor belts
go Microtiter plates
of bacterial growths.
They get cracked open,
the DNA gets precipitated,
it gets washed and cleaned
in all different ways,
reactions get set up,
and it chugs along
at a pulse rate
of one Microtiter
plate, about 96 clones per
minute, through the system,
processing 120,000 clones
in the course of a day.
You see a tremendous number
of machines in this picture.
You see only a
handful of people.
And that is correct.
The remarkable development team
over at the genome center that
built this robotics, in
conjunction with the company,
in fact is significantly larger
than the number of people
it takes to run
the robotics, which
is really quite delightful.
Once all the sequence
sequencing reactions come off,
we have to detect them.
And they go back to a room
of commercial detectors,
back in the back room.
We have a farm of about 145
capillary-based sequencers,
with a throughput of about 65
million letters of DNA per day.
That's a lot of
sequence per day.
And then all of
that goes upstairs
to the informatics
department, where folks
process this and assemble
this and extract something
from all the sequence.
It was a very interesting
year, from May
of 1999 to May of 2000, when the
amount of the genome that had
been covered in draft form--
not perfect form,
but draft form--
had grown, grew from about
10% of the genome to about 90%
of the genome, in the course
of one quite remarkable year.
This is roughly what the
year looked like, here.
It was month by
month, the genome.
And I could just look at this
again and again and again.
It just--
[LAUGHTER]
Really, I mean, let's
look at that again.
That's really--
[LAUGHTER]
That's really fun.
There you go!
That's all there is to
sequencing a genome.
No, this involved
a tremendous amount
of coordination of 20 different
groups around the world,
distributing clones, groups
working in all different sizes.
Our group at the
Whitehead Institute
was indeed the largest single
contributor to the effort,
but in fact there were
major, major contributions
from the Sanger
Centre in England,
from Washington
University in St. Louis,
from the Department of
Energy, from Baylor in Texas.
And then a number of
small groups, all of whom
played, I think, incredibly
important roles in keeping
this an international project.
In fact, the project was
so open that, halfway
through its scale-up phase,
the group in Beijing, China,
said they wanted to
join and we said, sure.
And Beijing brought in 1
and 1/2% of the genome,
done there in China.
The groups were all
very different in how
they approached
this, but they all
shared one absolute
commitment, which
was that the data,
however it was produced,
would be freely
released on the web
every 24 hours, without
restrictions of any kind.
That was the only
condition for signing up
to join the International
Human Genome Project.
It was a pleasure to work
with all these people,
and it was a pleasure
to do all this work.
And I've got to say, there's
just absolutely nothing
like just being able
to be left alone
and focus on your science.
And (EMPHASIS) this
was absolutely nothing
like being able to be left
alone and focus on your science!
[LAUGHTER]
We spent the entire
year, while we're
trying to sequence the
genome, waking up to newspaper
headlines all the time.
Because apparently,
I understand,
some company decided that
we were being slow about it.
[LAUGHTER]
And decided to create
a business plan,
that they were going to sequence
the human genome so much faster
than anybody else.
And they would therefore
have a proprietary database
that they could do
with as they chose.
To my mind, there was a
little miscalculation, there,
in that I think they mistook
what was the designated pilot
phase, where we were
attempting to figure out
how to do this thing
carefully and right,
for an inability to scale
up when we were ready.
And so, in fact--
I think somewhat
to their surprise--
they found that we were zooming
along just fine, doing this,
and that the business
plan which involved
having three-year window where
the sequence was exclusively
available through this
company really seemed to, um,
well, it didn't look
so good, after a while.
We'll come back to
what actually happened,
because, scientifically,
there was
a lot of very
interesting stuff there.
There were some
claims that they were
going to do this by a
much more powerful method,
the much-vaunted
whole-genome-shotgun method,
that, instead of dividing
the genome up into pieces,
they were going to toss the
whole genome into your blender,
press, you know, Puree, and be
able to sequence lots of pieces
and put it together.
And this was so much faster
than the silly old, you know,
know where you are and get
the whole thing organized
kind of way.
[LAUGHTER]
We're going to come
back to that point,
because, for the first time,
we know the answer of what
actually happened.
But, given all the controversy
of what was going on,
we decided that the
best thing to do--
I believe Senator Aiken really
gets credit for this strategy--
was simply to declare victory.
Right?
This was the old
Vietnam strategy, right?
[LAUGHTER]
In his case, it was declare
victory and withdraw.
We just declared victory
and went back to our labs
to get to work, you know,
finishing the genome.
Back on June 26, there was a big
announcement at the White House
that the human genome
had been sequenced.
Um-- at least, if
you read closely,
that a draft version
of the human genome
had been sequenced.
And, if you read really
closely, that the groups
claim that a draft
sequence of the--
[LAUGHTER]
Obviously, in our case, you
could check the web yourself
and see that there
was data there,
or that you would have
to analyze it yourself.
The case of the
company, you know,
go figure-- how would
you know, anyway?
But it didn't stop
the announcements,
and it was basically right.
Because there had been an
amazing milestone achieved,
which was that it was
no longer the case
that the lack of sequence was a
rate-limiting step for biology,
that, for the vast majority
regions of the genome,
you could get your
hands on the sequence.
But what we hadn't
done is analyze
that sequence, put it
together, neatly seen
what's in it, really
read through the book.
And, to my mind-- although I
realize it seems sort of pokey
and old-fashioned-- instead of
science by press release, to me
the real milestones come
with peer-reviewed papers.
And that's what in fact
happened this week.
That's what was
exciting, this week,
was that a paper appeared
in the journal Nature.
In fact, a remarkable collection
of about 20 papers appeared
in the journal Nature, one
of which [? cub-reports ?]
the sequence of the human
genome in an initial analysis.
Some others report other
related topics I'll talk about.
It appeared officially,
covered it yesterday.
We held a press conference
on Monday, to announce this.
And this picture
here, by the way,
is one we designed here at
the Whitehead Institute.
You may not be able
to see it closely,
but this is a
picture of DNA that
has been decomposed through
the photo-mosaic technique
into 1,500 human faces
from around the world.
And so, when you get your
issue of Nature, look up close.
We did this here,
and-- in fact, we
had this idea of
doing this here,
and then we searched the web
to find out where in the world
was that company that
made these photo mosaics.
And it was absolutely
delightful to discover
that this company that I'd
heard of but never really
paid enough attention to was
the product of an MIT graduate
and was, in fact,
two blocks down, just
by the Necco factory.
[APPLAUSE]
And so MIT pops up
all over the place.
You know, it was great.
Anyway, for fun, go try to find
the picture of Crick and Watson
in this picture.
[LAUGHTER]
There is a Where's
Waldo to this.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
It's there.
All right, so, a little bit
about assembling the sequence
of the human genome.
I realize many of you aren't
aficionados for this stuff.
I think I'm scheduled to give
a proper seminar in April.
This, as you can tell,
is not a proper seminar.
This is kind of fun to
celebrate this week.
Assembling the sequence
of the human genome.
Very briefly, we
had to produce--
and we did produce--
this is largely the work
of Bob Waterston's group
in St. Louis--
overlapping clone maps,
across the genome,
of large inserts clones,
each about 200,000 letters
in length, and then to select
from that a reasonable tiling
path of these large,
we called them BACs--
Bacterial Artificial
Chromosomes-- these large,
200,000-base-pair clones,
break up each of these things
into small, shotgun
fragments, sequence them,
and reassemble them into a draft
form that still had some gaps
but a modest number of gaps--
perhaps eight, nine gaps,
something like that.
And then, with
computer programs,
merge them all together
into overlapping sequences,
based on where we knew
these clones were.
And there's a very nice program,
written by a graduate student
at UC Santa Cruz, called
Jim Kent, called a "gig
assembler" that put all
these fragments together
in some nice way.
And the short version
of this is that there's
a fair amount of continuity.
You start initially with
about 22 kilobase contigs
of sequence.
Merging them, you get them
about 82 kilobase contigs.
Connecting them by links,
you're up to about a quarter
of a million bases.
They live within
larger clone contigs
that we have localized
all these fragments into,
that extend for more
than 2 million bases
and connect it to
about 5 million bases
and then are joined by
fingerprints into about 8
million bases.
And so, in fact, there's
a hierarchical arrangement
of each of these
fragments connected in.
There are still gaps
throughout this map,
but we know where the vast
majority of those gaps are.
In fact, almost all of those
gaps, 99% of the sequence,
is well localized to the human
chromosomes by this process.
It ain't perfect.
It ain't finished.
But, for every letter
in the sequence,
we've attached an error rate.
91% of the letters
in the sequence
are accurate to 99.99%.
95% are accurate to 99.9%.
The order?
Well, we've checked it
against all the previous maps
available.
It agrees pretty darn
well, although there
are the occasional
differences in the order.
Where we've checked
those differences,
so far they appear
to be problems
with the previous maps.
In fact, the
sequence seems to do
a pretty good job of cleaning
up the previous maps,
rather than vice versa.
But by no means will we assert
that any of this is perfect.
There's still
probably about a year
and a half's more work to
go to bring this to what
we call "finished state."
But, already, there's an
awful lot of genome there.
The connected pieces of
sequence, the sequences
are connected into scaffolds.
And together they span
about 2.892 billion bases,
which appears to be about the
entire euchromatic portion
of the genome.
The genome's probably
about 3.1 billion bases,
the rest of it being
heterochromatin
around centromeres
and other regions.
Now, of the 2.92, we
seem to have about 2.69
in our assembly.
That's about 92% of the
genome seems to be represented
in our assembled bases.
There are gaps.
There's about 149,000
gaps in the sequence.
But all but 2,000 of them
we have immediately spanned
by pieces, because they
live well within clones,
and they are all going back
through a finishing process
and getting closed up.
Because of the wonderful
mapping approach that was taken,
all these pieces happen to
live within a mere 2,000
components that have
to be put onto the map.
And the number of physical
gaps, where we don't actually
own a piece of DNA covering
it right now, is under 1,000.
Those are being worked through.
So that's a rough description.
In any case, this is all
just to say it's not done.
But it's pretty far along.
It's pretty far along.
Then there were our
friends at the company.
[LAUGHTER]
So I keep reading, in
the New York Times,
how they beat us at this thing.
It was really,
really fun this week.
We got to read the paper.
So they really did try their
whole genome-shotgun thing.
They generated a
whole lot of data
in house, about
fivefold coverage.
They report no assembly
of it whatsoever.
I assume, from the fact
that nowhere in the paper
have they attempted to
assemble their data,
that it didn't work at all.
Instead what they did,
if you read the paper--
and I invite my colleagues now
to read the paper closely--
was they took their coverage,
and they took the whole public
database, based on
seven-and-a-halffold coverage.
They didn't even break it
up randomly or anything.
They got out the screwdrivers,
and they carefully
unscrewed it into a perfectly
overlapping, tiling path,
with exactly equal,
big overlaps,
tossed it into their computer,
and then added their data
and attempted to
assemble a genome.
60% of the data that went
into the computer was ours.
It was not experimental
data, it was simulated data--
simulated, not even as
you do in a laboratory,
but with perfect overlaps.
Wish I knew how to generate
data like that in a laboratory.
Nonetheless, nonetheless,
the whole genome shotgun
still failed.
Despite all that, it covers
about 75% of the genome,
in contigs that you
can really localize.
If you ask, how much does
it cover, total, here's
what it looks like.
They call it-- the word "faux"
is their word, in the paper.
Their faux whole genome
assembly actually has about 88%
of the sequence
in it, although it
is in 119,000 separate pieces
that have to be localized,
far beyond which
you can localize.
If you take the biggest
ones, you can get about 75%
of the genome
realistically localized.
And about 25% of
the genome is in,
I guess the technical term
is, "tossed genome salad."
[LAUGHTER]
So the assembly that actually
got reported by our friends--
although this makes no
difference to the New York
Times-- was not that
whole genome assembly.
What they did instead,
when they realized
they had trouble with
this, was they simply said,
all right, we'll
take all our data,
we'll lay it on top
of the public clones,
in a clone-based
assembly, and we'll just
assemble the local bits.
So, instead of a
whole genome assembly,
they did assemblies on the order
of about half a bacterial log.
That, however, did work.
Of course, what it produced
was about 2.65 billion bases
of DNA.
The input to that, of course,
was our 2.69 billion bases
of DNA.
[LAUGHTER]
And it produced about the
same coverage of the genome.
So I mean, I don't mean
to make a big deal out
of this difference.
This is basically the same.
So I think in fact
what they did was
they rearranged our sentences
within our paragraphs,
or something like that.
I must say, after putting up
with three years of science
by press conference,
it is a pleasure
to read a scientific paper and
find out what really happened.
And, I got to say, there
were some pretty dark times
in the course of the
Human Genome Project,
when we felt, should we
just throw in the towel?
Was this really
possible to put up
with a steady drumbeat
of press telling us
that we're being silly for
being slow and wasteful
and all these things?
In the end, there would
be no Celera paper
but for the Human
Genome Project.
And you know what?
We're very proud to have
put our data on the web
and let them have our
data and all that.
The only thing I ask
is that they probably
ought to do a better job
of acknowledging, you know,
why they have an assembly.
But they're welcome
to the assembly!
The data's there
for everybody, even
for those who would like to say
that they're competing with us
or beating us.
That is the one great thing
about making your data freely
available, is because you
have no chance of winning,
because you give everything
to your competitors,
you absolutely are guaranteed
to have no chance of losing.
And that's important,
because we have
to win by giving
this stuff away.
All right.
Inter--
[APPLAUSE]
It's a good lesson.
Interpreting the
sequence of the genome.
So I want to put
aside all that stuff
and say, well, what's
in your genome, anyway?
Well, a lot of people around
the world combined their efforts
and put on all the different
annotations we know.
There is a browser,
at the University
of California, Santa
Cruz, where we display
all the different
RNAs that are known,
all the ESTs that are
known, all the similarities
to the pufferfish, tetraodon,
and mouses going on
in the next month or
two, all the repeat
sequences, and anything else you
want to know about the genome.
Either the folks at Santa Cruz--
Here's the Santa Cruz
browser, if you visit it.
You can zoom in or zoom out,
according to your preference.
You can scroll along
the chromosome.
You can set it for which
things you want to see,
which things you
don't want to see.
And, if you have any suggestions
for what else should be there,
let us know and it'll get added.
In addition, because we
believe in diversity,
the European
Bioinformatics Institute
has its own version
of this browser.
Same sequence is used, here,
but they put it up differently.
They have different approaches
to how they're annotating it.
The National Center for
Biotechnology Information
also is bringing up a browser.
And there'll be a lot of diverse
ways to look at this sequence.
There is also, when you get
your copy of Nature, this way
to look at the sequence.
We have a foldout-- in fact,
two roll-folds-- that come out
of the journal, with the
human genome on it, showing
the key features like
the density of Gs and Cs
and SINE elements
and LINE elements
and all sorts of things.
It is, I must say, not at
a terribly usable scale.
It's at a scale of 3.3 million
bases per centimeter, which
is--
[LAUGHTER] --beyond
My visual acuity.
But, in any case--
but it looks pretty to
put up on your wall.
But you notice certain
things from it.
In fact, going
back to it, you can
see, if your eye is really
good, that the GC content, which
is this black line, goes
up and down a fair amount.
The genes, there is some dense
urban neighborhoods of genes,
some rural neighborhoods,
here, of genes.
If you plot it, the
genome is really lumpy.
We're very lumpy,
compared to other species.
There are regions where
your GC content's 41%.
There are regions where it takes
an excursion out by 10% or 15%,
for periods of 10
million bases, before it
comes back down again.
And, you know, even a little
bit of statistics will tell you
this can't possibly
happen by chance.
In fact, there are very
distinct neighborhoods.
The GC-rich regions
appear to be gene-rich.
In fact, we have now great data
about how gene-rich they are.
They also, by the way,
correlate to many other things
such as chromosome
banding pattern.
There's a very
strong correlation,
where the GC-rich regions
correspond to the light bands
in chromosomes.
And, in one of the
companion papers
to come out in yesterday's
issue of Nature,
one of the consortium groups put
about 8,000 of the BAC clones
that had been sequenced
onto the cytogenetic map
and drew these
correspondences, which
is useful both for the
general statement but also
for, say, cancer
genetics, where one
can take cytogenetic
rearrangements
and correlate them now
to sequence, because you
have 8,000 tide points.
Now, you may know that most
of your genome is not genes.
In fact, only about 1% to 1 and
1/2% of your genome is genes.
Most of your genome
are repeat elements.
They're repeat sequences.
They are transposable elements
that have inhabited our genome
and hopped around, over
the course of hundreds
of millions of years.
From their point of view, that's
the purpose of our genome,
is to carry around them,
because they certainly
are the majority occupant.
They consider the genes
a necessary detail
in order to propagate the
transposable elements and all
that.
But, when you go
back to 15 years ago,
people said, ah, you know,
thee repeats, they're boring.
I might have actually thought
that, too, even five years ago,
but, I've got to say, they
are unbelievably interesting,
these repeats.
Very briefly, almost all
repeats in your genome
fall into four flavors.
One are called LINE elements,
one are called SINE elements,
one are called LTR
retrovirus-like elements,
one are called DNA transposons.
For example, the
LINE elements are
one of the great inventions
in the history of eukaryotes.
They are a transposable element.
They make an RNA that
goes off to the cytoplasm
and [INAUDIBLE]
reading [? frames ?]
it gets translated into protein.
The protein grabs the RNA
that made it, brings it back
to the nucleus, cuts the
chromosome at a site,
and reverse-transcribes it
back into the chromosome.
It's a completely self-contained
package for making an RNA,
getting the
machinery translated,
coming back to the nucleus,
and copying yourself.
You'd think, the
ultimate parasite.
SINE elements,
interestingly, are
parasites upon the parasites.
They encode nothing.
All they do is they make an RNA
that doesn't get translated.
There's no open reading frame.
They go off to the cytoplasm.
The only thing this RNA's
supposedly really good at
is grabbing the LINE
machinery away from a LINE RNA
and getting it to stick it
in the chromosome instead.
[LAUGHTER]
It's just-- it's just--
they have a lot of millions of
years to work this stuff out.
And it's very clever.
Retrovirus-like
elements, these things
also move by RNA intermediates
by a different mechanism.
They involve a gag and a
pol but not an env gene.
But otherwise they
look an awful lot
like the mechanism
of retroviruses.
And, indeed, it is
thought that these
were the precursors
to retroviruses,
that they learned first how
to do their jumping jacks
within a cell.
And then, after having worked
out how to do all this,
get reverse-transcribed,
whatever,
pick up a cellular
envelope gene, and depart.
Then there's DNA transposons.
They're very different
to the other three,
because they don't make RNAs.
What they do is
they make a message
that goes-- sorry--
they don't transpose
through RNA intermediates.
They make a message, it goes
off, makes a transposase,
the transposase comes
back to the nucleus,
cuts the chromosome and moves
the DNA element elsewhere.
These guys have a very different
life than the other guys,
because this is actually
a pretty crummy lifestyle.
If you're a transposase,
well, the problem
is that your transposase
gets made out there
in the cytoplasm, comes
back to the nucleus,
and tries to find who made it.
It would like to find
the element that made it
and move that element
preferentially.
Remember, the LINE
is smart enough
that the proteins grab
the RNA that made it.
That way, you ensure that
you're moving an active element.
The bloody transposase comes
back, doesn't know who to get!
It grabs anybody and moves it.
[LAUGHTER]
And therefore DNA transposons
are self-limiting infections.
Because, as they begin to build
up extra defective copies,
they become less and
less and less efficient,
and their lives are short.
OK?
So that's what you've got.
Now, a few comments.
We can put them all
into a family tree.
Because every
element, when it hops,
is a copy of something that was
an active element, initially.
Its siblings who hopped
about the same time all
started with the same
sequence, and then it
began to degenerate.
But we can, by evolutionary,
by phylogenetic reconstruction,
figure out that these 52
SINE elements are siblings
and they arose by virtue of
the number of changes that
are in them, about,
oh, I don't know,
5 million years or
10 million years.
And every single
element in the genome
can be put into families, and
those families can be dated.
So, in fact, we've done that
for all 3 million elements
of the genome.
And those dates are
really fascinating.
In particular, you can find
out that most of our repeats
are very, very,
very old, much older
than you see in flies or
worms or mustard weeds.
This tells, by
measure, by percentage
of interspersed repeats.
Another way to put it, though,
is for the human genome
the vast majority of repeats
in your genome hopped
before mammals, hopped before
the mammalian radiation.
There are fossils pre mammal.
And so they're quite old things.
But here's a shocker.
Despite the fact that
they've been hopping
for a billion years, despite
the fact that this is, you know,
the thing that's caused
your genome to form,
at the size it is, the
rate of transposition
is plummeting dramatically.
In fact, in olden days--
is this working?
Yeah.
In old days, here--
this is old, moving to now--
the rate of
transmission was here.
It went up.
But lately, the last
40 million years, it
has been in a plummet.
In fact, DNA transposons are
extinct, completely extinct.
These retrovirus-like guys are
almost extinct, if not extinct.
There is only a
single family left
that has hopped since our
divergence from chimpanzees.
And we can only detect three
possible active elements
that have open reading
frames that are full-length.
If those guys have
[? missensed ?] mutations that
inactivate them, that's it.
They're dead.
That's the end of the line
for LTR retrotransposition.
So there is a serious
ecological crisis,
with regard to the, you
know, endangered species
of transposons in
our genome right now.
[LAUGHTER]
And we don't know why.
But we do know that this is
not happening in the mouse.
Interestingly,
the mouse does not
show the same pattern at all.
Curiously, its rate of
transposition is not--
and there are 11 happy families
of LTR retrotransposons,
hopping around the
mouse genome, every day.
What's gone on?
We don't know.
We have some
interesting speculations
having to do with the fact
that it may be that our genome,
that our population, the
[? prominent ?] lineage,
has a very small
population size,
and we're much more subject to
the effects of genetic drift
that could let you
lose the small number
of active elements.
So that's my own guess, but
we have no evidence of this.
Rodents tend to have much larger
population sizes are much less
subject to genetic drift.
But we're going to
have to look at a bunch
more species to
know what's gone on.
Here's another weird
fact, just to show you
what you can learn by
staring at a genome.
You think genome
sequences are boring?
Wow.
Here's something really weird.
If you were a transposon,
where would you go?
Would you hop into
gene-rich, GC-rich DNA?
Or would you hop into
gene-poor, AT-rich DNA?
Well, if you were
a smart transposon,
trying to get along
with your organism,
it'd be sensible to hop into
gene-poor, AT-rich DNA, where
you'd do the least damage.
And, in fact, that's exactly
what the LINE element does.
LINE's endonuclease cuts
the chromosome at AAAAT.
And, in fact, that accounts
for the tremendous enrichment
of LINE elements in
AT-rich, gene-poor regions.
Seems a very sensible sort of
detente between the organism
and the genes, the organism
and the transposons.
SINE elements, however, show
exactly the opposite pattern.
They are highly
enriched near genes.
Now, A, that doesn't
make a lot of sense.
Well, why should they do that?
And B, far more importantly,
from the point of view
of biochemical mechanism,
how do they accomplish that?
Because I thought
I told you they
use the LINE
endonuclease to move.
Why don't they get
stuck in at AAAAT?
Two hypotheses.
Number 1, somehow
that RNA is so smart
that it could reprogram
the endonuclease
to put it elsewhere.
I don't know how to do that.
That's be a fancy bit of protein
machinery, protein engineering,
but maybe.
Alternative hypothesis--
they actually
go in in AT-rich
regions, but evolution
favors the retention
of those that are
near genes in GC-rich regions.
But the latter hypothesis
that I've just stated
would imply a function.
Well, we now know the
answer, because we
can look at the genome and the
genome will tell us the answer.
How do we know?
We can take all those
SINE transposons
and sort them into the newborn
ones, the adolescent ones,
the middle-aged ones,
and the old ones.
The newborn ones have a
distribution that look just
like the LINEs in AT-rich DNA.
As they get older
and older and older,
there's a 13-fold enrichment
for those near genes.
While there are some alternative
possible interpretations
for that, we strongly
favor the interpretation
that there's actually
selection going on for this.
And there was a hypothesis
proposed two years ago,
by [? Schmid, ?] that's
really fascinating that
proposes the mechanism.
Turns out that
these SINE RNAs bind
in a sequence-specific fashion
to a specific protein kinase
involved in the regulation
of protein translation.
Different organisms
have different SINEs,
but they all blind to the
cognate protein kinase.
Mutate them
slightly, they don't.
If you wanted to regulate
protein translation,
how would you do it?
Would you use a protein--
oh, sorry, one more fact.
SINEs, unlike other
transposable elements,
are expressed in somatic cells
under stress; others, just
in the germline.
Turns out, if you wanted to
regulate protein translation
under stress, would it be
smart to use a protein?
Nah, because you'd
have to translate it.
Right?
And that'd be kind of dumb.
You'd use an RNA.
And you'd want to
have a lot of it,
if you wanted to work
quickly under stress.
And you'd want it to
be located somewhere
in open chromatin, where
you could express it easily.
In other words-- of course,
this is backward reasoning,
but it might be quite reasonable
to use a high-copy-repeat RNA,
located near genes, if you
wanted to regulate something
as a stress response.
In any case, this was
[? Schmid's ?] hypothesis.
He had made it two years ago.
And the evidence we
have now, that there
is a rapid, within
25 million years,
reshaping of the
distribution of SINEs I think
provides a very interesting bit
of potentially corroborating
evidence for that.
Here's another interesting fact.
You can take transposons that
were born at the same time
and use them for epidemiology.
You can use them as if
they were a birth cohort
and say, if a transposon
landed on the Y
chromosome versus the X
chromosome, how does it do?
Is that right?
Yeah, that's right.
How does it do?
Well, if you look
at it, transposons
born at the same time
that land on the Y
have lots more mutations
than land on the X.
And from this you can infer--
and, in fact, back out--
that the rate of
mutation in sperm--
because Y chromosomes always
go through male meiosis--
is twice as high as in eggs.
Because X chromosomes spent
two thirds of their time
in female meiosis.
So you can, in fact, work
out the differential mutation
rates, by comparing things on
the X and the Y chromosome.
In fact, in this
particular case,
we have the pleasure of
confirming work of David Page,
about six months ago.
There had been a bunch
of previous studies,
trying to do this, that
got lots of wrong answers.
And David made a really
nice estimate of this,
about six months
ago, where he said,
we really think it is
a twofold, difference
based on one particular region,
about four million years ago.
And we can confirm
this now, based
on about 100 times as
many data, spread out
over 40 million years,
that David's suggested rate
of male-to-female
mutation is spot-on.
There are zillions of more
things I could tell you
about transposons.
I won't.
You know, I'd tell
you about the fact
that we get genes
from transposons.
At least 50 genes
in the genome, we
can recognize as gifts
from transposons.
We can also recognize
the most recent ones
to hop, the ones that are still
variable in our population
and could be used to trace
the history of our population.
But let me switch to genes,
because our genome does
contain genes, and they
are of some interest.
[LAUGHTER]
We have been attempting,
by looking at the sequence,
to identify the gene
content of the human genome.
Golly.
That turns out to be a lot
harder than bacteria or yeast
or worms or flies,
because there's
a signal-to-noise problem.
Our genes are only 1
and 1/2% of our genome,
whereas in flies
and worms and yeast
they're a big proportion
of a [? genetic ?] locus
is the coding regions.
50%, typically.
Whereas in us it's
a trivial fraction.
And so our ability to detect
these is nowhere near as good,
and the gene set currently
generated and described
in the paper is
nowhere near as good.
But, nonetheless, we
have a pretty good handle
on how many genes there
are, and we certainly
do have good chunks
of most of them.
And the answer is, there's
really only about 30,000,
35,000 genes.
I'll say 35,000 genes,
as a rough guess.
We've run it through all sorts
of estimation techniques,
statistical
estimation techniques.
We've also done direct
counting programs,
including one written
by Chris Burge here
called Genome Scam, which is a
successor to his famous GENSCAN
program, for finding
genes within genomes,
as well as a bunch of others.
And all the evidence
we get points
to the same conclusion--
about 35,000 genes.
So I owe an apology, and I wish
to make that apology right here
and now, to about seven years'
worth of students in my 701
course, because I have been
reporting the official number,
that there are supposed to be
100,000 genes in the genome.
And so I don't know that you're
entitled to your money back,
but, nonetheless--
[LAUGHTER]
Check with the
registrar on that.
But, nonetheless, I now wish
to correct that misimpression.
Actually, why did we ever
think there were 100,000 genes?
That turns out to
be very interesting.
We had to track back to what
was the origin of this round,
nice 100,000-gene number.
The origin turns out, very
clearly, to be down the road.
It's Wally Gilbert.
Wally did a beautifully
simple calculation,
in the early 1980s, that
a typical human gene
looked like it was
about 30,000 letters.
The genome was about
3 billion letters.
Divide one into the
other, you get 100,000.
And it's so round, it
made it into the textbooks
and just refused to go.
And, of course, it
was only meant to be
a back-of-the-envelope estimate.
If you tell this to Wally,
the reaction is, hey,
you know, we were
basically right.
Because-- Wally's trained as a
physicist, and, to a physicist,
a back-of-the-envelope estimate
that's within a half an order
of magnitude is just fine.
The problem is--
[LAUGHTER]
--that biologists think
that a factor of three
means something.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
And it really doesn't, not by
these estimation techniques,
anyway.
But there are a lot fewer genes.
We've taken the genes.
We've sorted them into
functional categories,
and things like that.
We can say a number
of things about them.
The exons tend to be
smaller, the introns--
the intervening spaces-- bigger.
There seems to be
more alternative
splicing, about twofold
splicing, in human genes, it
appears, than flies or worms.
So that, in fact,
although we don't--
The depressing fact is that the
total number of genes we have,
at 35,000, is only
about twice as many
as a nematode worm, C. elegans,
or only about twice as many
as the fruit fly
Drosophila melanogaster.
And, on the whole,
we like to think
that we're a lot more
complicated than that.
And so this has provoked
tremendous concern,
particularly in the
past week, about people
worrying about how we can
be so complex with such
an economy of genes.
One answer is, well, we make
more proteins out of them.
We do more alternative
splicing that clearly does
seem to be right.
Oh, another fact to mention
is that they are, indeed--
because now we can
tell-- a huge, huge bias
to the GC-rich regions, in case
you needed any confirmation
about this.
About a tenfold
enrichment, there.
But, when we look at our genes,
we ask, how are they new?
How are they different?
What explains what
makes vertebrate genes?
Well, first off, we are
not that innovative.
Most of the domains in
our proteins, they're old.
They're in invertebrates.
Only about 7% of all
the domains that we
can find in vertebrate
proteins appear
to be new to the
vertebrate lineages.
That is a surprise.
There's only one
enzyme that vertebrates
seem to have invented.
That's pancreatic ribonuclease.
But what we did do,
to get more genes,
was we created many
more architectures.
We put together the old
pieces in many new ways.
And we have considerably
more architectures,
any given domain appears with
many more genes in a human
than it does typically
in fly or worm.
There's a particular
emphasis of this
in extracellular molecules.
And I expect this has something
to do with the greater
complexity of our circuits,
is that we connect
the parts in many
different ways.
In addition, another bit of our
rather derivative innovation
is that, when we like something,
we just expand it dramatically.
Olfactory receptors.
The human genome shows about
1,000 olfactory-receptor loci--
1,000.
We actually count
906, at the moment,
that we've got well in hand.
And then there are parts
missing, and all that,
but it's about right.
Shows that vertebrates show
tremendous interest in smell.
It's one of the crowning
achievements of vertebrates,
is the spectacular elaboration
of smell receptors.
However, I'm sorry to report
that, having done this,
the hominid lineage decided
that it didn't really
care about smell receptors.
And two thirds of
our smell receptors
are pseudogenes, we can
clearly see from the sequence,
whereas mouse keeps its smell
receptors in pretty fine
working order, by comparison.
We seem, after all this
investment in the nose,
to have decided to
settle on the eyes,
instead, as a more
interesting sense.
And you can see it in what
we tidy up in our genome.
Immunoglobulin domains,
obviously a big part
of the genome.
We discuss some of that.
Intermediate filaments.
There are 127 intermediate
filament proteins,
including 111 keratins.
If you want to
describe a vertebrate,
you'd say it's
something that really
likes epithelial surfaces, all
sorts of specialized epithelia,
for these intermediate
filaments.
Growth factors.
We're into growth factors.
Big expansions [INAUDIBLE]
growth-factor families,
like TGF beta.
So, vertebrates are
things that like to smell,
have immune systems,
specialized epithelia,
and communicate and develop
with lots of growth factors.
That [INAUDIBLE] be us.
Also, we appear not to be
able to take credit for that
much-- for all of our genes.
Actually, about 223,
is our count, genes,
that we find in the human,
there is no homologue,
outside of vertebrates, in the
rest of the eukaryotic world,
but there are
homologues in bacteria.
That is, we have a close
relative in bacteria
but nothing outside
of vertebrata.
The likely
interpretation of this
is that these represent
horizontal gene transfers that
occurred early in the
vertebrate lineage.
Bacteria can, in fact, mate
with nonbacterial cells
and transfer DNA to them.
It's usually unproductive.
But, in fact, possibly
back when we were a fish,
some bacteria got with some
gamete and passed some DNA.
And this isn't a
frequent occurrence,
but we count about 223 of these.
It's, of course, conceivable
that some of these
are hiding somewhere
in invertebrates
we haven't seen yet.
And we may have to rethink it.
But, right now, the most
likely interpretation
is that these are indeed
horizontal transfers.
They're all enzymes, so
we didn't invent them.
They're not
characteristic of what
gets invented in vertebrates.
One of them, for example,
is monoamine oxidase,
important in
psychiatric disease.
Now, to extract all of the
information out of the genome,
we're going to need to line
up with lots and lots more
species.
And so already the
international consortium
is at work on sequencing mouse,
rat, zebrafish, pufferfish,
and various other species.
In a partnership
between Whitehead, Wash.
U, and Sanger, we've been
generating random coverage
of the mouse genome, to
be able to pick out exons
by cross-species homology.
The goal is to get about
threefold coverage.
We're already at
twofold coverage,
so I think the goal of
threefold coverage by the spring
will be met, and we'll
be able to line up
and, I think, identify
many of the exons
from the mouse rather directly.
But I think we're
going to be able to get
a lot more than just the exons.
Because, in fact,
I think we'll be
able to get much of the
regulation this way.
I'll give you just
one neat example
that emerges from looking
at the genome sequence.
We have a very important set of
genes involved in development,
called the HOX clusters.
These HOX genes occur
in four big clusters--
HOX A, B, C, and D--
that all are homologues to
things that arose in insects.
We've sequenced them now,
not just in the human,
but we've done
them to completion
in the mouse, the
rat, and the baboon.
When you line them up-- and
this is work of [? Ken Doer ?]
at the genome center--
they line up spectacularly.
I don't just mean "good,"
which is what you'd expect.
But, spectacularly.
That is, over 100 million
years of evolution,
they fall perfectly
on a diagonal.
There's been no
insertion or deletion,
to speak of, across these loci.
And, when you look closely
why, when you look closely,
you see why.
Remember, I told you
half of your genome,
50% of your
genome's, repetitive?
At the HOX cluster, it's 1%.
The HOX cluster has
essentially no repeats.
It admits no mutation
to repeat, either
in the human or the
rodent lineages.
There's no target for changing.
That means that
spacing and content
are very tightly conserved.
And that suggests
that this thing is
chockablock full of regulation.
And, sure enough, when we
line up the different species,
we can pick out more than
100 apparently conserved
regulatory features there.
I don't think this is
particularly special to HOX.
I think HOX is very
special in the way it's all
tightly conserved, and
spacing, and all that.
But I think, in fact, if we
can get the correct alignments
throughout the rest
of the genomes,
we will be able to pick up lots
and lots of regulation that
occurs.
Finally, I'll
mention very briefly
that there are a lot of other
applications of this that
are happening and that also are
represented in the papers that
appeared yesterday.
To apply the sequence
to humans in medicine,
we really need to understand
not just all human sequence
but all its variation.
We need to understand what's
the nature of variation
in the human species, and what's
the nature of those variants
that cause disease.
Well, in fact, over the
past couple of years,
particularly at
the genome center,
we've been characterizing that.
We've had a project to not
just sequence the genome
but begin to collect variants.
We did a project,
maybe three years ago,
which at that time
we called, foolishly,
"Large-scale survey of
variance in the human genome,"
where we reported about 4,000
single nucleotide differences
and could report that
the frequency was about 1
in 1,000-- actually,
[? about ?] 1,300--
that typical genes had only
two or three or four common
variants in the population, and
that, in general, we looked--
despite being 6 million people--
like we were really a
population of about 10,000.
And that's right, because we
are a population of 10,000.
We all trace back to a small
found population in Africa,
a mere 5,000 generations ago.
And we show it from
our DNA variation.
This is, of course,
very important,
because, if we have a very
little amount of variation,
we stand a chance
of characterizing
every variant in the genome,
maybe three or four variants
for each of 30,000 genes,
and testing each one
for correlation with disease.
[? Finding ?] doing
human genetics
may become a simple
matrix problem.
Write down all the variants
along the top, all the diseases
along the side, and fill in
the matrix, and just see.
That would be a lot of fun.
Well, if so, in
order to do that,
we need various techniques.
I won't fuss over these.
There are techniques called
"association studies"
where you directly
test variants.
Linkage disequilibrium studies,
where you indirectly test them
by ancestral haplotypes.
But what you need
for all of that
is to have zillions and
zillions of variants.
The goal is to have such a
dense map of single nucleotide
polymorphisms-- we
call them SNPs--
that you can comprehensively
test for disease association
anywhere in the
genome, by looking
for the signatures of
ancestral haplotypes
enriched in people with disease.
But you need a lot of them!
4,000, that we published
three years ago, is not much.
So, happily, a great example
of how industry and academia
can work together, the SNP
Consortium was founded.
A bunch of companies and a
bunch of academic centers
got together and said they
would pool their resources
and find 300,000 variants
across the genome
and put them all freely in
the public domain without cost
or any kind of
patent protection.
This got going
about two years ago,
and it has been
wildly successful.
It's a great example of how
industry and academia can
work together to
produce things that
are helpful to all concerned.
In addition, a bunch
of variants come
from just taking the sequence
and taking our clone-based map
and looking at the overlaps.
So the number of
SNPs, the number
of variants in the
genome, has grown
from when we reported,
right over here, 4,000,
and we were very
impressed with ourselves,
to basically the work
of three centers--
Wash U, Whitehead, and
the Sanger Centre--
vvvoomp!
And appearing
yesterday in Nature
was the companion paper
reporting 1.42 million variants
in the human genome.
We now have a variant, on
average, every 2 kilobases
in the genome.
We will push forward,
and we'd like
to get about 4 billion
variants or so.
But already we are
just up to our ears
in variants across the genome.
And we stand a very
good chance of finding
all of the ancestral segments
that occurred in the genome
and using them to trace disease.
I won't tell you about--
I'll skip over a
couple slides, here--
that we've also measured
how big those segments are,
and that varies
with populations.
But in northern Europe,
they're quite big--
on average, about 100
kilobases in total,
maybe 50 or 60 in either
direction, from a point.
In certain African
tribes, they're
much smaller
because the ancestry
is different in terms
of the age of the family
of that population.
But we're going to be able
to understand those and use
these for disease studies.
I'll skip over those factoids.
In addition, and I'm not going
to talk anything about it,
this work on the genome
is having a huge effect
on cancer studies, as well.
It's driving us in cancer
studies, and many other people,
to look at all the genes
simultaneously in the cell.
And I think the reporting
now of the full list of genes
means that we're going
to be able to make
really good microarrays, to
study the pictures of gene
expression in cells, finally,
with, for the first time,
comprehensive arrays.
All right.
Well, the goal has
been to try to create
for biology what the
chemists have had
for the whole last century--
a periodic table.
To have the parts list.
[INAUDIBLE] folks
call this stuff
the "holy grail" and stuff.
I'm not convinced
by any of that.
This is just a parts list.
But a parts list is
a very useful thing.
We are now closer than I
had thought we might ever
get to such a parts list.
We don't have fully all the
nucleotides, but we will.
Give it another year or so.
We don't have fully
all the genes,
but we have the vast majority
covered, to, the vast majority,
their lengths.
And give it a year or two,
and that will be there.
And we also have, by the way,
the isotopes, the variants
on the elements--
namely, those SNPs.
I think it's probably fair
to say that you could already
start planning your experiments,
counting on the fact, now,
safely, that all of
that will be there,
that the periodic table
will be up on your wall
in the next year or two.
Won't be perfect yet.
It'll take--
Actually, the periodic
table wasn't perfect,
when it first went
up on the wall.
They spent 20 years
filling in all the holes.
Right?
It didn't cost them quite
as much money, back then,
but they spent a
lot of time, filling
in all the holes, right?
[LAUGHTER]
And so none of these
things are ever perfect,
but the conceptual
framework there is there.
I think it'll have
a big effect on us.
Before I close, though,
I have to reemphasize
what I said at the beginning.
This was different than any
other project in biology.
When you stand up usually, and
you give a talk in biology,
you talk about your
work or your work
and a couple of
graduate students
or some postdocs or
something like that.
This is a project where
there's nobody who can
take personal credit for this.
This is something that
happened because of the way
everyone agreed to pull
together and share the work
and share the credit.
The group that did the most
to bring this to fruition
is shown here, on the snow.
This is the Whitehead Genome
Center, over in the park,
in Charles Street.
This was the only place we
could find we could actually
take a picture.
There was no indoor
location we could actually
manage to get the
whole genome center
and still have a camera stand
back far enough to get them.
But this is the folks.
And one could not ask for
a better set of colleagues
and friends to have worked with,
over such an extraordinarily
exciting, at times stressful,
but always exhilarating time.
And so I am in tremendous
debt to my colleagues, here.
I will not name the names
of all 250 people associated
with this.
I will in particular single
out Lauren Linton, who
did an amazing job at mounting
a scale-up for the center,
in the course of this project.
And I do particularly want
to thank Chad Nusbaum, Bruce
Birren, and Mike Zody, who have
been the assistant directors
of the center, who have
managed all different parts
of this effort.
But there are heroes,
throughout this entire picture.
In addition, there are
groups around the world
that contributed tremendously.
This is a picture of the first
Bermuda meeting that occurred.
It was in Bermuda,
really, truly,
amongst the different
international centers.
And I owe great
debts to colleagues
in different countries, and we
all are still working together.
But the only really appropriate
credit slide for this talk
is that.
This is the first
talk where you really
just have to put up the
whole globe and say,
we done it together.
And it was really,
really satisfying,
to go to Washington this week,
with so many of our friends,
and realize that, for
something that we had started--
in my case, many cases--
15 years ago, we
actually had done it--
not all quite finished,
but we'd done it
well enough that we knew there
was now no doubt it was all
going to get done.
And I confess I tend to be
pretty inured to these sorts
of things.
I'm not, you know, one to
get soppy about this stuff.
But, by the end
of day on Monday,
I had realized that this is
kind of the surprise, in a way,
is that only in retrospect do
you realize how history ends up
happening.
It happens sort of just by
doing your work every day,
on something worth working on.
And, 15 years later, we all
who have been working together,
here in this community,
on something,
just working on the right next
step and the right next step,
realize that, over 15 years,
collectively, we all did
manage to make
quite a difference.
And so it's really fun to
come, this week in particular,
and just share it
with the community.
Because it's all of ours.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SHARP: Do you have many
of your colleagues here?
LANDER: There are some,
at least, right over here.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LANDER: Yeah, I don't know how
many [? of them, but ?] yes.
[APPLAUSE]
SHARP: In the tone
of Eric's comments,
I'd like to everybody
who participated
in the genome-center work
who's in the room to stand up.
And let's thank them, too.
Come on!
[APPLAUSE]
LANDER: [INAUDIBLE]!
SHARP: Eric would be pleased
to take a few questions.
This is a big crowd, but we
can take a few questions.
LANDER: Not from
people who I work with.
[LAUGHTER]
SHARP: No, not from people who--
LANDER: You can ask me tomorrow!
[LAUGHTER]
SHARP: A few-- please.
AUDIENCE: [? How many ?]
[? of the genes are ?] involved
in intelligence?
LANDER: The fraction of genes
involved in intelligence.
[LAUGHTER]
It depends on the definition.
SHARP: [INAUDIBLE]
LANDER: If you mean the
fraction of genes which,
when knocked out, disrupt
your intelligence,
it's probably like we've
always taught-- half, or more.
If you include
being dead as being
an insult your intelligence--
[LAUGHTER]
--then it's a very
large fraction.
If you want to
know what fraction
of the variation in
intelligence in the population
is attributable to variation
in genes, we haven't a clue.
And my own guess is--
I mean, this is the
usual question of,
how much genetic determinism
of intelligence there is--
there's nothing in our sequence
that tells us much about that.
And what I do think I find most
interesting in our sequence,
because I think it's
a point worth making,
is that the very fact that we
are so extraordinarily similar,
across the species, that
we're 99.9% identical,
only one difference in 1,000--
this holds across the whole
planet--
and that we come from such
a small founding group,
tells me that the
population genetics have not
changed in 5,000
generations but we
ourselves have changed
opportunity [? and ?] society
and what's possible
and what we think
men or women or people from
different groups can do,
so dramatically.
So I must say, realizing how
the gene pool has not undergone
significant reshaping,
in that huge time,
and yet society can come out
so different-- that is to say,
what we do with our
brains and what we do with
our intelligence has so many
degrees of freedom, there,
that I'm not too worried about
what the genome is ever going
to tell us about limits on
what we can possibly do,
because we have
tremendous evidence that,
within whatever
limits there are,
we've been able to
have huge variations,
[? and ?] [? a lot's ?]
within our control.
SHARP: Over here?
Oh, here, first.
LANDER: Sorry, uh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
30,000, 40,000 genes.
What about all those companies
that are [INAUDIBLE] marketing,
you know, we have a
database [INAUDIBLE]..
SHARP: Repeat the question.
LANDER: So, given that there
appear to be only 30,000,
40,000 genes, the question is
that there are, for example,
ads in several journals
that say, subscribe
to the X database,
which has 120,000 genes.
[LAUGHTER]
So, let's see-- the
markets have closed.
I could say, well, one response
potentially would be to sell.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
Another response would be that
the New York Times actually
has begun to probe Insight
Pharmaceuticals, now called
Insight Genomics,
on this question.
Because the ad I just
quoted is from Insight.
And, according to
the New York Times,
the chairman of Insight--
I think it was the chairman--
the president of Insight
said to the New York Times this
week that, oh-oh, we actually
meant 120,000
distinct transcripts,
but they actually come
from 40,000 genes.
So, in fact, that one,
if I take correctly
what was in the New
York Times, appears
to have just been retracted.
And it was just the detail,
that they meant transcripts
not genes.
But Bill Haseltine at
Human Genome Sciences
is rock-solid sure that
he's got 120,000 genes
and that he's not giving
any ground on that.
And so I propose the following
really fun challenge.
We get to specify
1% of the genome,
and anybody who
wants to disagree
produces the genes
they claim they
have in the 1% that we picked.
We'll check them together
and see if they're right.
If they have three times
as many genes in that 1%,
then we'll believe that they've
got gold in the other 99%.
But if nobody wants
to take us up on it,
it's tough to deal
with the claims.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LANDER: Future priorities
for other species.
Well, what this is telling
us is that sequencing
is a tremendously powerful
way to get information
you never imagined before.
Like, all these
repeats, all this stuff.
Clearly, experiment is
never going go go away.
Experiment is our
primary driving force.
But it's a great way
to form hypotheses.
So my sense is, already mouse
is underway, rat is underway,
zebrafish is underway,
two different pufferfish
are underway.
I believe that several
of the organisms
along the lineage leading to
vertebrates, like [? Ciona ?]
and such, will be sequenced
in the next couple of years,
in order to figure out what
were the key innovations.
Chimp is a very
interesting debate.
I can tell you
already, there's going
to be 50 million
differences with chimp,
because we know what the
percent difference is.
I just don't know which ones
are going to be important.
And there's an active
debate in the community
as to whether we should
race to sequence chimp
or that we should figure
out what in the world
we'd do if we had the
50 million differences.
And I think what'll happen
is there'll probably
be light coverage of the chimp,
to see if we can interpret
those differences.
Most of them are
probably just noise.
Right?
And, if we can figure out,
is it 10 that mattered,
or 10,000 that mattered,
how are we going
to know before we go overboard?
I have a feeling that, as the
cost of sequencing comes down--
already, yeasts!
And it's no big
deal to do bacteria.
Right?
And I think it's going soon
be no big deal to do fungi.
And I can't see why
we wouldn't just
continue to sequence
lots of organisms,
as the cost comes
down, because it's
telling us what is the greatest
lab notebook in history.
Evolution, it
turns out, has been
taking notes for 3
and 1/2 billion years,
in its lab notebook.
Now, it did not have a good
course on research practices,
because--
[LAUGHTER]
--because it only takes notes
on the successful experiments.
It throws away the
unsuccessful experiments.
[LAUGHTER]
But we got the notes on
the successful experiments.
I mean, obviously, we
don't want to criticize it,
because it got started before
these procedures were required
of graduate students, et cetera.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's a pretty
good lab notebook.
SHARP: Over here, there's--
LANDER: Yeah.
SHARP: --and
[? then-- ?] question.
We will end in a
couple more questions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I may
have missed a quote, when
you explained how you
were going to apply,
once you have the
sequenced genome,
how do you use that to--
how would you apply
that knowledge?
Like, once you have
the sequenced genome,
how do you use it?
I'm not sure I--
LANDER: okay.
So what I didn't really
say, and I apologize,
in many different ways.
One way, make an expression
array, where you put down
a piece of DNA
complementary to every gene,
take the messengers from a
cell, wash them over, and see
which genes are on and off.
By having a comprehensive
list of all genes,
you know you have a description.
Here's another way.
Produce full-length
CDNAs for every gene,
and actually express the
proteins in appropriate places.
If you're a
pharmaceutical company,
test a small molecule that
has an interesting biological
action, but you don't know
what its target is, for binding
against all 30,000 genes.
And, if it has a
side effect, test it
against all 30,000 genes to
find out what other things it
may bind to.
Look at all the interactions
between those things.
I mean, in some
sense, it's asking,
why have a periodic table?
After all, it doesn't
define the experiment.
The genome sequence doesn't
What it does, though,
is it converts
the search for every answer
into a search in a finite list.
It means, with the
periodic table,
I can look it up
on the mass spec.
If I know what I saw go by, and
its mass and a few properties,
I know what it was.
Increasingly, in biology,
we're going to be in a world
where, when we see
something happen,
we can know what it
was that just happened,
what particle went by,
what protein it just was.
Whereas, in the past, almost
any phenomenon we were studying,
we had to spend months
or years figuring out
what just did that.
And I think what it
is is the great boon
to the graduate
student of the postdoc,
because usually the graduate
students and postdocs spend
most of their time tracking
down what the part was.
Which is kind of boring,
compared to the phenomenon.
Now they can study a phenomenon.
And the tools aren't all
there, but four or five years
from now, maybe,
it'll be much easier
to describe that phenomenon
[? in ?] working parts
and get on to real experiments.
That's what it's for.
SHARP: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] what you
think it's going to happen now,
how many--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LANDER: We sort of--
one gene, one protein.
What happens to that?
Well, of course, "one
gene, one protein"
is the official doctrine in 701.
But, even in 701,
we did acknowledge
that that wasn't always
the case and that there
was alternative splicing.
I mean, viruses have been
good at this for a long time,
of being able to put together
other transcripts and such.
And we've known about
this for a long time.
What it means is that there
will be a more intensive study
to figure out, when
you make three proteins
from the same gene, how
different are they, really?
They're not radically
different proteins.
They're variations on
a theme, typically,
with some extra domain.
And I think some [? serious ?]
work will have to go to that
question, of what this
domain's-- you know,
the extra domains
do accomplish there.
But I think, as
with all of biology,
I mean, the central
dogma isn't strictly
right, and "one gene, one
protein" isn't strictly right,
but, you know, it's not bad.
It's not bad.
SHARP: okay, this is
the last question.
LANDER: Last question.
SHARP: Last question.
AUDIENCE: How well were
you able to sequence
over the centromeric
and telomeric regions?
Were you able to
[? define ?] [INAUDIBLE]??
[LAUGHTER]
LANDER: So the BACs
that were sequenced
were prioritized not to be those
in highly repeated regions.
We do seem to recover a
decent number of clones
for those regions.
But, because they tend
to be strongly repeated,
they got put at the
bottom of the list.
And so we poke
our way, our head,
into the telomeric and
the centromeric regions,
but we haven't dealt with it.
And I'm not sure how well we're
ever going to do it, really,
cleaning up two megabases
of centromeric repeat,
or whether it matters.
SHARP: Last question
[INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: So, many
of the genomes
that [? can ?] sequenced,
above 50% of the genes
have no known function.
Is this the same in
the human genome?
And what steps can
be taken to identify
the functions of those genes.
LANDER: So that's a
tremendously important question.
In most genomes that have been
sequenced, 50% of the genes
have no known function.
Is that true for the human?
And what steps are we taking?
Ah-- depends what you mean
by "no known function."
If you say, what
fraction of the genes
have no recognizable
domain that we could--
you know, being a protein
kinase, I suppose,
is a function.
But, then again, for what
purpose is it a protein kinase?
So, if you're willing to say,
I know it's a protein kinase,
or it does-- you
know, it's a GPCR--
that counts enough--
60% of the genes we can
attach functions to.
Some bit of biochemistry
associated with the gene.
If you're asking, what's
their real role in the body,
in some meaningful sense, oh,
golly, it might be you know,
12,000 or so, might be
a third of the genes,
that we have pretty
good ideas of what
they're doing in the body.
And, of course, even there
we're often surprised.
Right?
You know, apolipoprotein E
that was carrying around,
you know, lipoproteins
in our blood system
turned out to be in our
brain and predispose
to Alzheimer's disease.
So it's pretty primitive.
We don't know what most
of these genes really do.
That is the work, I
think, of the next decade,
is to attempt to
find as many ways
to characterize these
genes by where they're
localized in the body,
under what circumstances
their transcripts are
turned on, you know,
where they are subcellularly
what they interact
with through partners,
what happens when I make
a small molecule that
binds to each of them,
to figure out what
function I disrupt.
By no means is this a
comprehensive description
of life.
This is really--
I mean, I'm fond of calling it--
it's the parts list
to a Boeing 777.
You know all the screws, you
know all the seat cushions,
you've got the fuel gauge,
you've got all the pieces,
and they're all spread
out on the floor.
Right?
We don't yet know how
to screw it together,
and we don't know
why it flies, but--
[LAUGHTER]
--it's sure better than if we
didn't have the parts list.
I shall close, with that.
SHARP: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]